data science is at the forefront of
every business sector it has been widely
used in companies to make sense of vast
volumes of data and draw insights for
business decisions python is one of the
best programming languages when it comes
to solving data science tasks and the
reason why python is so popular for data
science is because of its wide
collection of libraries python supports
a range of interesting libraries for
data analysis data manipulation data
visualization and machine learning so if
you are curious about learning the top
data science libraries and their
important functions then we are here to
help you with that simply learns skill
of course on python libraries for data
science will give you all the necessary
skills and experience to perform data
science tasks and solve real world
problems easily
you can start your career in data
science by learning the essentials of
python and its libraries free of cost
you will receive a course completion
certificate by simply loan this
certificate can be highlighted in your
resume to cast the attention of
potential recruiters isn't that awesome
simply learns python libraries for data
science course on skill up is developed
by experienced professionals and
trainers and can be taken by anyone who
has passed to become a data scientist
this course will help you perform
numerical analysis data analysis data
wrangling data visualization statistical
analysis and web scripting using python
libraries such as numpy band ass and
matplotlib you will also learn to build
machine learning models using
scikit-learn and tensorflow the total
duration of this free python libraries
for data science course is 7 hours and
all the modules are self-paced video
lessons with 90 days of access to the
course
this allows you to learn at your own
pace and convenience now there are no
prerequisites or eligibility criteria to
register for this free course yet
knowledge of basic python programming
and statistics would be highly
beneficial
so head over to our course page and
enhance your career in data science by
enrolling to our free python libraries
for data science course today sign up
now and get certified with simply loan
the link is in the description box
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here